foreign
how can we help
hi thank you so much for taking my call
you bet
um my main question is if my boyfriend
and I should split rent 50 50 or by
percentage of income in the future
say what
are y'all are y'all moving in together
um so we've been discussing living
together in the future I'm 22. he's 23.
um he just graduated from college last
year and he's making 79 right now I'll
be done this year with I'm making 65k
and I said I would prefer to be engaged
before moving in together and we're both
lucky enough that our parents are fine
with us staying home saving up money
doing the baby steps but he wants to get
a town home in a year and a half from
now and wants me to move in with him and
says he intends to marry me and that he
proposed before two years if we get
along living together
I would say if you were my sister or my
daughter or my good friend I would say
he is out of his mind I would agree okay
um and in this I'm going to give this to
you like I'm a Christian guy I teach
Sunday school sometimes okay so I'm
going to put that out there that's not
like I'm bringing this this is the data
couples that move in together are more
likely to get divorced
because here's why you play house you
practice you feel like you're practicing
marriage
but you're do it without the
the in like like hammered into concrete
come what may we're still going to be
here together
and so you it's it's like it's like
jumping out of an airplane and your
parachute isn't fully tied up yet
and so I can tell you if it wasn't for
marriage there's multiple times over the
course of my 20 years with my wife we
would not still be dating we would have
broken wow but we're married and we both
committed to each other we're in this
come hell or high water this is
happening and so we stuck it out and we
had to figure out how to do something
differently okay so that's what here and
let me give you the other thing that's
making me more uncomfortable than that
um I also have to be honest there's been
plenty of people who move in together
get married and their lives are fine
okay so I'm also gonna I know that
exists I don't like the fact that you
put a value down and your boyfriend blew
you off and said actually we're gonna do
this
and if you're already doing that now
that makes me very uncomfortable about
the future direction of this
relationship you said I at least want to
be engaged I want to have all this paid
off I wanted this I wanted this and he's
like nah
if you move in with me in 18 months you
can try out for me for six months and
then I might I might uh I might get
engaged after that screw that dude
forget that and Celeste he's also saying
uh I get the benefit of you helping
cover some of the yeah some of the
mortgage you pay my bills and you can
practice being my wife and then I'll let
you know in six or eight months uh if
you if you made the team Celeste you
wanna if I was thinking because he said
it would be more like I rent is really
expensive here too so he'd be helping me
out too oh how cute oh that's what
happens oh no that's what he spun it he
did a good job of selling you on it but
here's the deal you want to find out if
this dudes for you or not
all right but here's okay but listen you
want to know I'm gonna tell you how to
know and John you correct me if this is
too intense but I I think I got it
here's what I would do I'd say you know
what I thought about this
and
I initially asked you to put a ring on
it before we got into this decision
I don't feel comfortable with what you
came back with because there's so many
risks you can quote some of the stuff
that John said go get your own data and
just say whatever you want to do and
then I'd say okay I'm gonna go a step
further though
I'm going to take advantage of the offer
that my mom and dad have made for me and
I'm not going to move in with you until
we get married
okay okay and then just stop
just stop my ultimatum no no no no no no
not an ultimatum this is what I want to
do if he hears it as an ultimatum and
runs that's on him that's where I'm
going with this I think he's going to
reveal pretty quickly how much he wants
you in his life because to John's point
this dude's got all kinds of conditions
that honestly
all benefit him
oh wow okay okay he's got a live-in
girlfriend who pays half his rent he
wins we we wins this is friends with
benefits I think that that's about it
and you helped pay down his mortgage and
then y'all break up and oh all right and
by the way I've got I've got several
friends that I've known since I was Zero
okay we were like toddlers together I've
got several folks that I know from
middle school
and they are dramatically different
people when they were 22 than they were
when they were 11 and they're super
different now that they're in their 40s
both good and both whoa
so just because you got history doesn't
mean it's always right and now yeah I
want you to also take this Ken and I are
are pushing on you I'm not telling you
to go dump him today that's something
that's a decision you got to own you
can't call them and be like hey these
two clowns on the radio told us and
that's on you that's right but we're
trying to say
we both have daughters we both got wives
we both got colleagues here and great
friends who are strong professional
women listen
I I don't like someone blowing your
needs off just being like ah this is how
we're gonna do this you're worth more
than that yeah and listen uh Echo what
John said so let's listen to me we're
not saying dump him I'm saying give him
an alternative Vision if you believe in
that and I just told you what I would
say you may say all right I'm gonna wait
until the rings on the finger but I got
to tell you I want to see that this dude
is committed to me uh let me just give
you one other opinion that's based in
experience yes please I'm gonna hit 25
years of marriage in May okay wow thank
you I'm not saying that to to get the
congratulations I'm telling you what
John said Is Right
Stacy and I will celebrate that
milestone
not because we're great husbands and
wives all the time not because we've got
a quarter you're not going to see a
marriage book coming from Ken and Stacy
Coleman
but we made it because we committed it
was all in if Stacy had said I want to
wait to move in I would have said you
got it because I wanted to marry Stacy
I still want to be married to Stacy I
want to stay married to Stacy that's why
I've done all kinds of things and John's
right I got married at 23. I'm not the
same guy thank God that I was when I'm
23 but I also got a woman that's walked
through that Journey with me we've
gotten better as individuals we've
gotten better in our marriage and we've
had some tough times and and really
excruciating pain that we've had to walk
through together all I'm saying is we
need to know if this guy is all in for
the future and if he is it's not an
ultimatum you're giving him it is what
you believe is right for you okay in
relation to us and we're going to find
out real quick is he in it for the
benefits or is he in it for Celeste and
listen uh last piece of little wisdom
before we hang up on you
under no circumstances if you do move in
with him knock your lights out do not
co-sign on a mortgage together until
you're married it creates a whole big
legal mess don't do it don't do it don't
do it